cuando empezaste a trabajar gráficos por
computadora 1995 toy story y bueno
cuando era estudiante en la preparatoria
formaba parte del personal a cargo del
anuario escolar y trabajar como parte
del personal a cargo de la nor escolar
fue un esfuerzo muy gráfico y artístico
pero también era muy hábil en
matemáticas cuando fui a la universidad
como que descubrir la magia de la unión
de estas dos áreas podía ir a la escuela
aprender matemáticas aprender cómo
programar pero al final de cuentas crear
arte cuando llegué a pixar empecé como
ingeniero de software de renderizado eso
significa que de hecho escribí a las
fórmulas matemáticas de esa ecuación de
renderizado para ganarme la vida
y con el tiempo me cambié del área de
software al área de producción y ahora
estoy a cargo de todo el proceso de
renderizado de principio a fin en una
película así como de cualquier nueva
tecnología necesaria para crear una
película así que mi título es supervisor
de tecnología global y renderizado creo
que uno de los problemas más grandes que
tiene pixar actualmente es el concepto
de escalabilidad porque el renderizado
se vuelve cada vez más caro más
físicamente realista
y entre más caro es más computadoras
necesitamos para realizar el trabajo y
entre más computadoras hay para realizar
el trabajo se nos dificulta más hacer
que todo el sistema de computadoras
trabaje eficientemente
y eso es realmente esencial para
mantener los costos de renderizar una
película a un nivel razonable bueno
sinceramente creo que una de las razones
por las que soy tan hábil con las
matemáticas es que soy diabética he
tenido diabetes tipo 1 desde que tenía 5
años y todo lo relacionado con la
diabetes es una ecuación hay que comer
15 gramos de carbohidratos y eso
equivale a una unidad de insulina y todo
lo que hace es de hecho ahora tengo una
gráfica tecnología asombrosa que me
indica el nivel de azúcar en mi sangre
cada 5 minutos así que puede buscar
tendencias puedo digamos correlacionar
si esta es la cantidad de alimento que
tome en mi última comida y este fue el
resultado como puedo cambiarlo la
próxima vez y ese tipo de tendencias
dedicamos cómo debo corregir la
situación realmente se extrapola muy
bien a lo que hacemos en una granja de
render uno intenta pensar en cómo buscar
patrones y tendencias en una granja y
trata de tomar decisiones sobre cómo
podría modificar eso
patrones y tendencias para cambiar el
resultado la próxima vez de alguna forma
la diabetes me predispuso a esto